foreign
we were warned repeatedly by by Russians
from Yeager gaida the kind of liberal we
effect to like to Vladimir Putin the
kind of Russian we absolutely despise
repeatedly that the expansion of NATO
was going to lead to trouble we did
nothing about it and I think we need to
take some interest in that fact and to
stop pretending that this is a purely
one-sided event and also we need to have
as a country a serious discussion which
dissent is allowed almost every time I
say things like this uh I'm I'm accused
of being a Putin apologist by people who
can't pronounce the first and don't
understand what the second means of
being some sort of Traitor and I've said
lots and lots of pictures of dogs
bottoms on the internet which is what
happens to anybody who takes his view as
it's stupid because a country which
doesn't debate its own foreign policy is
the sort of country which which for
instance invades Suez and and gets
involved in the erosion invasion of Iraq
we need debate on foreign policy and
dissent should not be smeared in this
frankly puttanesque way that I faced so
anybody he's planning to do when he put
his smearing I'm ready for you and it is
extraordinary how little we in this
country know about Continental Europe
especially anything east of the old and
I think we should be a great deal more
careful about getting involved in things
and so we know more about it I was
astonished that we actually have for the
first time in my lifetime a major
shooting war on the European continent
which might actually become a nuclear
war and far from trying to bring it to
an end or seek peace my government is
pouring weapons into it
we certainly do know nothing of it if
you're a prime minister then what would
you do I'd be straining every sinew that
I had to try and bring about peace talks
I think you wouldn't give them any
emotions the most important I think I
think if you see a fire do you pour
petrol onto it or do you pour water onto
it feeding weapons into this is is uh
it's prolonging it but if they didn't
have the weapons Russia would actually
win so you had people like macron
achieve peace talks the idea that that
Britain's contribution to this uh matter
is crucial seems to me to be as with so
many of our views of ourselves in the
world wholly overblown and conceited uh
the this is a war between the United
States and Russia being fought on
Ukrainian soil our contribution is
purely as so many of our foreign policy
actions are to do with tonying to the
Americans rather than hoping to achieve
any other results so do you think the
Americans shouldn't have given that I
think I think the Americans have have
having having uh well let me let me let
me avoid too much too much early
controversy here and so I think the
Americans have a larger responsibility
than any other Nation apart from Russia
to help bring about peace and I think
that we and all the other major nations
of the world should be using our good
offices both in private diplomacy and
through the United Nations to persuade
them to do so I don't see any
alternative to the West standing with
Ukraine in order to defend its right to
exist there's also a self-interested bit
here Ukraine gave up nuclear weapons and
the Budapest memorandum China Russia and
France none of what we weren't in this
maybe were just distracted at the time
um China Russian and France signed a
agreement with them saying we guarantee
your your territorial Integrity as look
if you give up your nuclear weapons
they did and then we didn't
to put in ripped up the Budapest
memorandum I have friends at the front
in um leftists you know people who here
will be really anti-government at the
front
one of my friends his name is taras
billus and he's an editor of a magazine
about about the commons okay and I met
him two days before the war broke out
he's now at the front they sent me a
picture of their the only heavy weapon
in his unit which is a Maxim gun
any of you military historians will know
that Max higher and Maxim invented this
gun in 1898 and it was in if you've ever
played little toy soldiers with Russian
Second World War toy soldiers they're
the little machine guns with a shield
okay that's the heaviest weapon he has
if we hadn't sent them weapons better
than that he'd be dead everybody else
would be dead the torture chambers of
isium will be taking place in Kiev it's
to portray Ukraine and some poor
pitiable unarmed country is slightly
misleading if I'm a sophistic I need to
Arms from somewhere if you look at the
Ukrainian Army even now it says bmps
t-72 C6 t62s grants the it's armed with
Soviet year equipment and its Army is
organized as a Soviet Army it's just
that they don't want to live in a
post-soviet reality are all the young
people I met there want to live in a
western reality and that is their right
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas